the best animated features go that extra
mile to immerse viewers helping the
audience forget that the characters
they're investing in have been drawn in
pencil or rendered with pixels all of
that hard work is so easily undone by a
simple mistake however and they happen
at the top level more than you think are
a few misplaced pixels going to ruin a
great animated movie not at all
mistakes are unavoidable but when you do
actually notice one of these errors it
ends up becoming impossible to unsee Toy
Story Pixar's surprise hit Toy Story
blew audiences away in 1995 it
outperformed blockbusters like Goldeneye
Batman Forever and Jumanji at the box
office to become the highest grossing
film of the year and taught us all some
valuable lessons about playing the toys
so play nice but this critically
acclaimed smash hit isn't completely
perfect the mistakes begin during the
opening credits as Andy plays with these
toys he drives avi into his makeshift
cardboard Bank but in the next scene he
comes out of the closet the mistakes
continuous Buzz Lightyear arrives on the
scene as the clueless Space Ranger
attempts to take flight he slides down a
Hot Wheels track and does a full loop
though this clearly wouldn't have been
possible the shot from his point of view
reveals that his wingspan is way too
light that was falling with style The
Lion King just one year before Toy Story
changed animation forever
Disney released The Lion King this truly
memorable movie smashed previous records
to become the highest-grossing
hand-drawn film of all time and went on
to become the best-selling VHS ever
according to The Daily Beast the house
of the mouse didn't even have its best
animators on the job with the a-team all
assigned to Pocahontas instead maybe
that's why the animation often has some
jarring mistakes
for example the whites of Simba's eye
turn yellow in certain scenes
knowledge I switch from blue to green at
different points in the movie to Shrek
DreamWorks big breakthrough Shrek wasn't
afraid to lean heavily into the realm of
toilet humor and that was one of the
things that made it such a huge hit for
the studio
Shrek subverts the typical Disney tropes
right from the get-go wake up right even
the opening credits are quick to
establish that this isn't your typical
hero
unfortunately the animators must have
been having so much fun showing Shrek
brushes teeth with insect guts that they
forgot right to left in the scene shrek
creates a beware ochre sign for his
swamp but did you ever notice the
mistake here when he's painting the sign
we can see from behind it the top left
corner is missing but when he plants it
in the ground and we see it from the
front it's the top right corner that's
missing does it ruin the movie
hardly but good luck not noticing it
whenever the scene comes up I guess you
don't entertain much do you I like my
privacy you know I do too that's another
thing we have in camp Monsters Inc the
tiny details that the animators of 2001
monsters Inc had to contend with took up
a lot of their time which is probably
why some glaringly obvious mistakes
managed to make it into the final cut
during one sane hapless karageorge
Sanderson emerges from a child's bedroom
with a little white sock
stuck to his shoulder triggering a red
alert George and I are like brothers
the child detection agency shows up to
dispose of the supposedly dangerous item
with a controlled explosion shaving the
monster bald for good measure it's a fun
but ultimately flawed scene because when
Sanderson is pinned down by the CDA
toxic sock has somehow flipped over the
Lego Batman movie it might have fallen
well short of 2014's the lego movie in
terms of box office returns but the Lego
Batman movie still raked in a ton of
cash globally critics and audiences
loved it even if it isn't a perfect
movie some of the mistakes made by the
animators get lost in the madness of the
movies many action set-pieces but when
the Lego Batman movie slows down you do
start to notice the cracks a little
during the scene in which Bruce Wayne
talks through the portrait of his dead
parents the pictures to either side
change around between shots look at that
the old gang frozen Disney's frozen is
always likely to do big business the
studio must have known it was on to a
winner just based on the incredibly
catchy songs but nobody could have
predicted that frozen would take over
the world the way it did Elsa is the
star of the show but her sister Harlem
also seems to be capable of a little
magic apparently she can let solid
objects pass right through her body
after she realizes that Kristoff has
been the one for her all along anna
surprises him with a brand new sled to
replace the one he lost while helping
her in his euphoria Kristoff picks on up
by the waist and gives her a romantic
little spin but hit your pause button
mid swell and you'll see that his thumb
actually goes through on his waist it's
a blink and you'll miss it moment but
now that you know about it you won't be
able to unsee it
wreck-it Ralph this colorful Disney hit
route the majority of critics when it
came out in 2012 however just like the
80s arcade games it features wreck-it
Ralph comes with the odd glitch
we're not talking about vanilla Peas
predicament there's one who cannot
escape because she's a glitch in the
opening moments of the movie
Ralph explains his job within the game
fix-it Felix jr. essentially he wrecks
the game single building well the hero
Felix is tasked with fixing it yeah
naturally the guy with the name fix-it
Felix is the good guy he's nice enough
as good guys go definitely fix the stuff
really well we get a quick run-through
of how the game works and at the end of
the explanation Felix is awarded with a
medal while Ralph gets tossed off the
top of the building by the nicelanders
if you look closely there's something
wrong with this scene from a wide angle
we see that Ralph is standing right next
to the ledge during the ceremony yet in
the close-up shot that follows he's now
square in the middle giving the
residents of the apartment building
enough room for a run up someone's mama
probably wasn't too proud of that moment
you want to go peepee and your big boy
slacks keep it to yourself
it's make your mama's proud
[Music]